[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
avec tv 78 nous sommes le lundi 21
janvier tout de suite les titres de ce
set 8 journal plus de cent cinquante
patrons français comme étrangers réunis
par emmanuel macron au château de
versailles le deuxième sommet tous
france se déroule aujourd'hui à la
veille de l'ouverture du forum
économique de davos est en pleine crise
des gilets jaunes le président de la
république se fixe un objectif
convaincre de continuer à investir en
france la cité royale où se tenait hier
une cérémonie religieuse en présence de
2500 personnes l'ordination de
monseigneur bruno valentin s'est tenue
en la cathédrale saint-louis nommé par
le pape l'ancien curé de la paroisse
montigny voisin devient évêque
auxiliaire de versailles
et puis samedi l'association format
citoyens a lancé son école de commerce
de trappes une vingtaine de jeunes va
suivre des cours le samedi à la
pépinière saint-quentinoise promo paul
cette formation associera les
professionnels du monde de l'entreprise
le président de pharma citoyens nous
staff à larbaoui est notre invité à
suivre également dans cette édition la
présentation du week end inattendu c'est
un événement solidaire au profit de
l'association n'attend le combat d'un
ange versailles qui a donc accueilli
aujourd'hui les grands patrons de france
et du monde le deuxième sommet choose
france s'est déroulée toute la journée
plus de 150 chefs d'entreprise ont
déjeuné avec le premier ministre edouard
philippe et ont rencontré ce soir
emmanuel macron le but de ce sommet de
convaincre et ses grands groupes de
continuer à investir en france plus de
600 millions d'euros devraient être
déboursés cette année par ces
entreprises d investissement en léger
recul par rapport à 2018 mais mieux
répartis sur le territoire
et parmi les grandes annonces à venir
ibm va ouvrir en mars prochain de
nouveaux locaux sur le plateau de saclay
adecco va de son côté embauché dix mille
personnes cette année dont 1200 issus
des quartiers prioritaires les réactions
au micro de nicolas dans prix aura lieu
vers la france
parce que c'est un pays où on peut faire
beaucoup de choses des projets
d'investissement recherche et
développement c'est un pays où se
trouvent beaucoup des ingénieurs de
haute qualité donc c'est vraiment un
pays autre qualité toute la france forme
des personnes qualifiées dans la
recherche ainsi leur recherche et
développement et performante et ça
permet d'investir dans de bons projets
aujourd'hui en fait on parle
d'investissements en france et je crois
que c'est surtout ça qui est important
et conséquence de ce sommet le château
de versailles est resté à toute la
journée fermé au public ce soit encore
la circulation pourrait être est
difficile aux abords de l'édifice le
stationnement et lui interdit sur les
parkings de la place d'armes et de
plusieurs rues autour du château de
versailles le pape françois l'a nommé en
décembre bruno valentin a été ordonné
évêque auxiliaire de versailles une
fonction qui n'avait plus été occupée
depuis 1966 et la disparition de la
seine-et-oise la cérémonie d'ordination
s'est déroulée hier en la cathédrale
saint louis en présence de plusieurs
évêques sur place patrick jacques de
dixmude
c'est un véritable bain de foule qui
attendait bruno valentin plus de 2500
personnes ont assisté à son ordination
la cathédrale saint-louis de versailles
quelques jours avant de fêter son 47e
anniversaire l'ancien curé de montigny
voisins le bretonneux devient
officiellement évêque auxiliaire de
versailles c'est un grand moment de joie
cet après midi pour les catholiques d
évident mais pas seulement il y avait
aussi des représentants des musulmans
des juifs avec des élus qui étaient là
et on a vraiment partagé la même joie
c'est un moment d'entousiasme etc ça
d'abord le souvenir que j'en garderai
dans un contexte sensible pour l'église
catholique bruno valentin aura la charge
d'épauler l'évêque de versailles
monseigneur aumônier dans
l'administration du diocèse un
territoire qui s'étend sur l'ensemble
des yvelines il est le seul à occuper
cette fonction d'évêque auxiliaire en
ile de france
il ya beaucoup à faire je vais continuer
avec lui et avec plus de
d'enthousiasmant encore et comme si
j'avais plus d'énergie dans le public
des curés et fidèle que bruno valentin a
côtoyé lors de ses passages à trappes
château ou encore montini voisin joie
pour le diocèse
c'est vraiment ça va être un nouvel élan
pour diocèse et c'est une joie qu'on
partage avec tous seraient c'est une
très belle cérémonie très priante est
vraiment entouré de tous les prêtres du
diocèse c'est une cérémonie superbe et
là on a vraiment on est heureux d'être
chrétien la communauté chrétienne de
trappes était très représentée
aujourd'hui pendant cette messe
d'ordination voilà on n'a pas oublié il
sera resté à l'écouté de chacun et est
très simple dans ces rapports
monseigneur bruno valentin va rencontrer
prochainement la personne à l'origine de
sa nomination le pape françois à rome
toujours à versailles les lycéens et
étudiants avaient rendez vous samedi
avec leur orientation le palais des
congrès accueillait à la 8ème édition du
salon de l'étudiant en yvelines salon
qui s'est déroulé à quelques jours de
l'ouverture du site parcours sup le
reportage de patrick jacques de dixmude
et de rians universités alternance ont
encore école de commerce ou d'ingénieur
plus de 80 exposants répartis dans une
douzaine de secteurs étaient réunis au
palais des congrès de versailles
un salon de l'étudiant destinée
néanmoins un large public
les parents sont de plus en plus
nombreux sur les salons à venir
accompagnés
les lycéens donc il faut savoir qu'on a
beaucoup de lycéens dès la seconde qui
recherchent avoir des informations sur
leur orientation post-bac
mais nous avons également des étudiants
de bac + 1 à bac 8 5 qui reçoit des
informations sur leur poursuite d'études
là les choix vont se faire rapidement
donc on essaye quand même de les guider
sans être trop sans leur mettre la
pression
après des recherches d'informations sur
leur orientation il sera temps de faire
un choix pour les élèves de terminale à
partir du mardi 22 janvier tout se
passera sur le site parcours sup lancé
l'année dernière la plateforme nationale
d'admission postbac suscite encore
quelques inquiétudes
c'est que j'ai toujours toujours rien eu
apparemment je trouve ça franchement ça
m'a fait c'est clairement avec mon
entourage
on l'a vécu l'année dernière c'est un
peu déstabilisant et la raison aussi
pour laquelle on leur dit de bien
travailler pendant ces années là les
futurs étudiants auront jusqu'au 3 avril
pour formuler et confirmé leurs voeux
les premières réponses
il faudra patienter jusqu'au 15 mai et
on continue de parler formation avec mon
invité mustapha larbaoui bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le président de formats
citoyen de l'association a lancé samedi
officiellement son école de commerce de
trappes l'inauguration s'est déroulée à
la pépinière saint-quentinoise promo
paul pourquoi après toutes ces actions
format citoyens lancée maintenant cette
école de commerce
alors d'abord pharma citoyens une
association créée il ya plus de dix ans
disent qu'on a créé en 2007 précisément
et en fait il ya plusieurs départements
dans la dans l'association est
voilà moi j'étais souvent identifié
comme le président du club de foot on a
fait beaucoup de choses en prétextant du
foot pour faire de l'éducatif mais c'est
vraiment ce que j'aime faire le plus un
point d'époque c'est un point de départ
et donc il n'y a pas que le foot pour
tous pour faire simple il n'y a pas que
le foot il n'ya pas que le sport mais il
ya également la culture et puis il ya
l'éducation nationale
c'est la raison pour laquelle on est une
académie avec des cm2 renfort maths
français depuis plus de cinq ans elle a
l'idée c'était de dire voilà je veux
m'occuper des cm2 mais je veux me guide
m'occupe également des post bac et d'où
l'idée il ya quelques mois maintenant de
créer l'école de commerce de trappes
ça s'adresse vous le dites aux 18 25 ans
voilà donc des 18 25 ans jeunes qui ont
eu leur bac niveau niveau bac n'ont pas
forcément avec le bac d'accord et je
pourrais vous expliquer pourquoi
mais niveau bac et plus 18 25 ans et
c'est une
alors pompeusement école de commerce de
trappes je tiens à le dire on n'a pas à
rivaliser cachot s'est tout de suite
mais l'idée c'est d'être sur un segment
différenciant d'une école de commerce
classique
je voudrais que tous les intervenants
soient des professionnels dans
l'entreprise qui viennent parler de leur
expérience de ski de ce qu'ils vivent en
entreprise ces départs et nollet les
cours se dérouleront le samedi mais ça
va être plus des master class avec des
professionnels bravo je retiens là je
retiens le mot effectivement des master
classes se sont que des professionnels
qui vont parler de leur cv leur
expérience ça parle déjà aux jeunes de
voir des professionnels de lin de
l'industrie 2,2 des corps d'état de
l'administration de la finance voir que
finalement ils ont eu un parcours pas
forcément classique et qu'on peut
réussir
alors évidemment on préférerait avec le
bac et plus mais il ya aussi de la place
pour d'autres
donc l'idée c'est l'expérience des uns
et des autres pour transmettre les
facteurs clés de la réussite pour
l'intégration en entreprise c'est
impossible d'écouter tout de suite
d'ailleurs l'interview de deux de ces
professionnels qui participent à à cette
école ainsi que l'interview du parrain
récoltés par patrick jacques de dixmude
mustapha et moi nous avons rencontré le
long de notre carrière de gens qui nous
ont tendu la main pour nous aider et
maintenant nous avons aussi ce devoir de
tendre la main à des jeunes gens qui
sont sortis du circuit scolaire et
cetera nous sommes la vie et moi pour
aider ces jeunes gens à entrer dans le
circuit du travail c'est sa route aura
une attention un échange avec m
bien sûr mi parcours mon expérience
professionnelle et des conseils les
dans leur intégration dans la vie
professionnelle partagé d'expériences
individuelles
cantona rial pour me dire
[Musique]
juste avant de dire un mot sur le
parrain est ce que le temps avance dans
cet entretien on le sent dans ses
interviews le l'idée c'est de la
transmission transmettre son expérience
c'est aussi l'idée de cette école de
l'asthme
c'est vraiment la transmission c'est des
mains tendues comme il a pu en avoir il
a une ex ligne il a une histoire
absolument extraordinaire faut quand
même savoir que ce monsieur est et n'est
franchement de tout ce qui est plus bas
pour devenir numéro un mondial du
transport du gaz en france donc c'est
une personne absolument avec un parcours
extraordinaire
donc c'est vraiment la transmission les
codes encore une fois la transmission et
puis ceux qui ont qui sont intervenus
sont effectivement les épreuves de cette
école voilà ils ont ils ont tous dit
pour le coup le plaisir d entendre
d'ailleurs vous le disiez sur les
profils d'élèves on a interrogé on
n'aura pas le temps de l'écouter
malheureusement mais on interrogeait un
élève qui a par exemple une formation
d'école d'ingénieur c'est à dire que
c'est des profils totalement différents
qui peuvent venir dans cette école
l'école de commerce de trappes encore
une fois s'adresse à tous ses étudiants
mais ce type d'école ce type de
transmission un moment donné ça ça va ça
tous les corps de métier on a toujours
quelque chose à vendre on a toujours
quelque chose à promouvoir le sur
quelque chose à mettre en avant et ses
éléments qui permettent la réussite de
l'entreprise basque ont pour le coût 30
distillé par nos profs et et voilà donc
je suis très très content de cette
nouvelle aventure j'ai un objectif c'est
la certification
oui bien sûr ça vient de commencer donc
on parle on part de pas grand chose ce
sera le samedi parce que on peut avoir
des salles que le samedi ce sera 3
heures parce que c'est difficile mais
bien sûr on y mettra demain des cours de
marketing de stratégie de voile à 2
politique de géopolitique bref tout ce
qui peut se faire j'ai fait moi-même
à chaud c'est donc on y mettra beaucoup
de choses mais il fallait commencer on
va commencer et on reviendra ici pour
vous en parler au fur et à mesure eh
bien vous accueillera à nouveau pour
plus d'informations je vous invite à
contacter l'association via l'adresse
mail qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci mustapha larbaoui je rappelle que
vous êtes le président de forme a
remercié moyens le traditionnel rituel
en janvier des cérémonies de voeux se
poursuit vendredi la mère de la verrière
avait convié ses habitants à la salle du
scarabée est les élus qui pour certains
avaient revêtu une blouse blanche pour
alerter sur le manque de médecins dans
la commune en 2019 là derrière la
concertation sur le projet de la zone
gare beckham va débuter rénovation du
cimetière construction d'une crèche sont
aussi prévus dossier phare d'ici la fin
de l'année
le projet de rénovation du quartier du
bois de l'étang sera validée est les
propos sont recueillis par nicolas
landry par une ovation debout de l'étang
qui continue son bonhomme de chemin
c'est prendre à dire on a eu beaucoup de
deux réunions de concertation petit à
petit le projet s'affine
et on devrait
avoir un projet officiel fin d'année
2010 9 vont être
proposer aux habitants de deux voire
trois scénarios
ces scénarios la bon on verra les
inconvénients et les avantages de chacun
ce qu'on peut changer ce qu'on peut
garder extra et puis
on mettra en place une façon de faire
qui permettra à tous les habitants ne se
prononcer sur une page culture à présent
samedi c'était la troisième édition de
la nuit de la lecture un événement
national pour promouvoir la littérature
à cette occasion le ministre de la
culture franck riester s'est rendu à
rambouillet il est venu au pôle de la
lanterne assister au speed booking
organisé entre bibliothécaire électeurs
qui ont pu échanger avec lui et
d'ailleurs dans le cadre de cette
troisième édition de la nuit de la
lecture saint-quentin-en-yvelines
proposait des animations la médiathèque
du canal à montigny le bretonneux
accueillait les plus jeunes soirée pour
un public plus averti à la commanderie
d'elancourt mais le but de la
manifestation était le même à donner le
goût de la lecture patrick jacques de
dixmude et aurélien ans
exceptionnellement les enfants avaient
le droit de veiller un peu plus tard ce
samedi 19 janvier au programme pour
cette nuit de la lecture à montigny le
bretonneux lecture d'histoires pour
petits et grands coloriage ou encore
fresque participative
l'idée c'est de donner avant la
bibliothèque autrement en soirée dans
une ambiance assez particulière les
enfants sont captivés les parents aussi
il nous fait participer enfin il ya
toutes les dimensions qui font que on
passe un bon moment ça va montrer bien
une soirée autour de la découverte du
continent américain sous toutes ses
formes compte folklore gastronomie et
danse
[Musique]
lorsqu'on a aimé c'est le côté un peu
l'international avec des lectures en
espagnol en anglais
et puis la diversité 6 mai lancement de
la lecture mais aussi de la musique de
la danse de la culture en général quoi
un type se réveilla des morts
autour de lui les deux autre ambiance à
la commanderie d'elancourt où la lumière
tamisée était de rigueur au coeur de
l'exposition memento corpus une
quinzaine de comédiens et poètes se sont
succédé sur scène toute la soirée thèmes
choisis pour leur déclamation la lecture
sur tout ce qui tourne autour de la
lecture du mot delà de la phrase de la
bibliothèque du métier du livre c'est un
lieu d'échangés formidable parce que on
est tous là les uns et les autres des
gens qui sont dans le théâtre ou dans le
dans la lecture etc et on vient un peu
se montrer chacun bascons en magasin est
ce qu'on sait faire
[Musique]
ne parlez plus de soirée mais deux
week-ends inattendu un événement festif
et surtout solidaire au profit de
l'association n'attend le combat d'un
ange déjeuner dîner et même goûter
spectacle le samedi 16 et le dimanche 17
février au cabaret du bout des prêts à
cerner la ville pour en parler les deux
invités au top
stéphanie concevoir pense à vous est la
maman de nathan présidente de
l'association n'attend le combat d'un
ange bonsoir franck et d'art nous ce
soir
journaliste à m6 on vous voit notamment
dans le 19 45 et vous êtes le parrain de
cette association vous allez nous
présenter dans un instant le programme
de ce week end inattendue alors on
attend
stéphanie c'est un garçon courageux de
11 ans que nous suivons depuis quelques
années déjà il est né le 21 novembre
2007 et ses fans il souffre d'une
maladie neurologique il handicape
lourdement
il ne marche pas ne parle pas et n'est
pas autonome dans la vie quotidienne
c'est une maladie rare seulement 15 cas
en france oui c'est la mutation d'un
gène depuis avril 2018
on a enfin le nom de la maladie donc
c'est la mutation du gène atp 6
v1 à c'est un protocole de recherche
dans le mondial qui se fait donc au
départ il y avait cinq cas nathan
faisait partie des cinq premiers
répertoriés et maintenant on arrive
aujourd'hui à 15 mais peut-être que dans
un an deux ans trois ans sait pas on
aura peut-être plusieurs cas en tout cas
maintenant c'est connu chaque enfant
peut être diagnostiqué avec cette
mutation du gène en 2008 quand on lui
diagnostique cette maladie peu d'espoir
d'ailleurs sur la suite de sa vie
pourtant aujourd'hui
nathan à 11 ans et a fait des progrès où
en est il mais au départ c'est son
avenir était assez sombre puisqu'on ne
connaissais pas du tout et puis ça qu'il
avait des crises d'épilepsie en
permanence aujourd'hui donc à 11 ans
aujourd'hui l'autonomie on a eu ma très
peu mais en tout cas grâce à tous les
stages de stimulation intensive à
barcelone qui ont été réalisés donc là
on est déjà très ce stage nathan tient
assis se déplace sur les fesses se met
tout seul aussi à si la position
allongée
ils poussent sur les jambes pour obtenir
de boer malheureusement il n'a pas
encore l' équilibre mais est comment
dire il se muscle pour pouvoir
éventuellement avoir cet équilibre et
tenir debout tout seul et marché après
la finalité des progrès réalisés vous le
dites des stages à barcelone qu'est ce
qui s'y fait non ces stages
alors ces quatre heures de stimulation
intensive par jour nous on attend c'est
le plus tôt le matin qui qu'il est on va
dire motivés et on va dire en forme
donc ces quatre heures de stimulation
qui qui se déroule principalement avec
donc léa et samuel c'est la kiné alors
dakine et comme on a en france sauf que
c'est beaucoup plus intensifs donc la
kiné manuel de la kiné dynamique
c'est-à-dire avec des derniers
dispositifs on arrive à maintenir debout
et donc à lui c'est de lui faire
apprendre les pas pour envoyer
l'information à son cerveau pour qu'ils
puissent l'intégrer surtout parce que
racontent les liaisons toutes les
liaisons ne sont pas faites donc il faut
pouvoir réaliser toutes ces raisons et
donc par des exercices pour pouvoir que
le cerveau comprennent l'intérêt de
réaliser bad et pas dé tenir debout
voilà mais on a vu quelques images du
dernier stage réalisé à barcelone c'est
des thérapies qui sont coûteuses non
remboursés oui alors c'est en espagne
donc aucun organisme français finance il
faut compter trois semaines de stage à
peu près tout compris à peu près 5000
euros donc c'est une grosse somme mais
bon vu les progrès ça vaut vraiment le
coup et maintenant on a vraiment besoin
il attend avec impatience ces stages à
chaque fois pour pour retrouver l'équipe
évidemment mais parce que c'est vraiment
en espagne qui travaillent énormément
comme ça il est suivi la semaine à 10 m
avec une kiné mais c'est vrai que c'est
pas suffisant en termes de clients fin
c'est que une demi heure à peu près par
semaine donc c'est trop peu pour lui il
a vraiment besoin d'eux des d'être
stimulée en permanence thérapie coûteuse
d'où l'important ce qu'il y ait cette
association pour récolter des fonds pour
financer ces thérapies et aussi avec
l'aide de vos proches de personnalités
comme franck et d'art qui est vous êtes
le parrain de cette association nathan
le combat d'un ange pourquoi avoir
accepté d'être le parrain qu'est ce qui
vous a touché dans le combat de nathan
c'était l'occasion j'animais ya quelques
quelques années l'une des soirées cave
est organisée au profit de l'association
et puis à l'époque stéphanie gates on
m'avait proposé de devenir le parrain de
l'association s'étaient plutôt bien at
on entendu qu'on avait passé une très
belle soirée autour autour de nathan et
du coup j'ai accepté de mettre à profit
ma petite notoriété pour faire connaître
l'association et puis poursuivre un peu
plus l'association est et nathan et vous
serez aux commandes notamment avec tony
bastion du cabaret du bout des prêts
pour ce week end
inattendu
pourquoi la soirée inattendue est elle
devenue un week end inattendue parce que
la soirée était elle était devenue
tellement attendu on a décidé de se
renouveler un petit peu et puis aussi
ont refusé en refusé pas mal de monde
deux personnes qui ne pouvaient pas
finalement venir assister à la soirée du
samedi soir donc on s'est dit avec avec
stéphanie avec tous les autres bénévoles
sonia christian et tony qu' il fallait
pas aussi pour récolter plus d'argent
pour l'association a proposé d'autres
spectacles à d'autres horaires trois
rendez vous pendant ce week-end un
déjeuner spectacle samedi 16 février à
midi un dîner spectacle le soir et un
goûter spectacle le lendemain dimanche
17 février à 14h30 quel est le programme
franck je sais vous trépignez
d'impatience à l'idée de connaître le
programme est notamment de savoir ce qui
aura pour le goûter
je reconnais là bien là votre côté
gourmand en terme d' artistes il y aura
adriano c'est un chanteur de pop de pop
latino on aura quand disparue ce qui est
déjà venu qui est chanteuse et
comédienne que l'on a pu voir notamment
dans la comédie musicale notre dame de
paris mais aussi dans les misérables
elle est passée il ya quelques dons aux
oeuvres ips le télé crochet de tf1 il y
aura black eduardo qui lui magicien il
est suisse lyon n'a pu l'apercevoir
aussi à la télé de c'était dans la
france a un incroyable talent j'ai mis
une petite note parce que beaucoup
d'artistes charles ibrahim alias magic
automates il est magicien aussi ça fait
plusieurs années qu'il vient participer
aux événements de de nathan lui à faire
de la magie en close up
il va passer de table en table pour
faire des tours de magie on aura réuni
marceau il est l'initateur mars
orphelins fossé survivre et chansons
donc il nous fait l'amitié de revenir ça
faisait quelques années qu'il n'était
pas qu'ils n'étaient pas venus on aura
du speed painting avec rené bès qui va
jeter les paillettes sur sur un tableau
et ce qui nous permettra une fois qu'il
aura fini de découvrir quels personnages
la destinée et puis il ya une artiste
qui va vous intéresser
greg vous ainsi que wilfrid rieschick et
votre rédacteur en chef parce que je
sais que vous avez été vous même limites
professionnelles en gymnastique ces
civils qui co et pole dance acrobatique
ouais ouais ouais vous n'aviez pas le
niveau donc vous êtes noir était
beaucoup plus tôt puis il y aura
naturellement tony bastian et toute la
troupe du cabaret du bout des prêts qui
nous accueille le samedi et le dimanche
et dimanche il y aura donc robin et pipo
pour le jeune public pour le jeune
public est un jeune public
j'en profite pour vous annoncer qu'on a
plusieurs palaces parisiens des
pâtissiers de palaces parisiens qui vont
et bien nous nous offrir quelques
quelques gâteaux qui seront vendus au
profit d' au profit de l'association
voilà il y aura naturellement plein de
surprises et isabelle morini-bosc d'rtl
qui va qui va venir passer une tête on à
jean philippe doux qu'on a pu voir sur
m6 france 2 etc qui va venir également
et à vos camarades de radio sensations
qui vont venir aussi monter sur scène
hugo casadamont match finances qui vont
peut-être chanter et faire un peu de
magie
on compte sur vous aussi peut-être je
sais pas si vous avez au delà de la
gymnastique si vous avez un autre talent
caché va vous pouvez vous pouvez venir
voir grégory sur sur scène
et puis si je crois qu'on a fait on a
fait le tour qui aura comme d'habitude
tout un tas de surprises qui vont venir
s'ajouter à la dernière minute donc
c'est important de suivre les réseaux
sociaux facebook twitter parce qu'on va
annoncer très régulièrement les
différents artistes qui vont venir et
puis les quelques personnalités les
people qui vont venir en toute amitié
sur scène il ne faut pas attendre pour
réserver ce week end
inattendu c'est le samedi 16 et le
dimanche 17 février au cabaret du bout
des prêts à cerner la ville stéphanie
quirion 30e merci d'avoir été avec nous
sur ce plateau
merci
[Musique]
et c'est un entretien bien sûr
enregistrés on retrouve tout de suite en
plateau et en direct miquel et demi
d'euros bonsoir bonsoir et ahuri comme
chaque lundi avec vous on va faire le
tour des résultats sportifs du week end
[Musique]
l'actualité sportive chargée michael on
commence par comme toujours elle
direction plaisir à la série noire
continue pour plaisir les jaune et noir
ont concédé une quatrième défaite de
suite en nationale 3 les plaisirs oies
se sont inclinés contre haguenau sur le
score de 35 à 31 ce dimanche à domicile
les plaisirs aux a mené pourtant le 3
buts à la fin de la première période on
écoute la réaction de l'entraîneur
victor garrigues et à la fin du match
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup d'amertume parce que on mène à
plusieurs reprises de quatre buts et on
remet systématiquement l'adversaire en
selle en ayant bien trop d'échecs passes
ratées tirs manqués sur des solutions où
l'adversaire n'a pas forcément provoquer
notre note défaillance après bon
adversaire s'est battu jusqu'au bout non
qui mérite sa victoire ça pas là le
débat mais on donne beaucoup trop de
cartouches à notre adversaire
et quelles sont les conséquences de
cette défaite au classement alors cela
devient compliqué un pur plaisir on va
le voir au classement cette défaite face
à un adversaire direct dans la course au
maintien aura peut-être de lourdes
conséquences pour la suite du
championnat
les plaisirs oies sont actuellement
lanterne rouge de la poule avec
seulement deux victoires depuis le début
de la saison mais le capitaine benjamin
modeste ne perd pas espoir
l'avenir c'est cette boulot déjà c'est
repartir à l'entraînement
costaud vaillant et puis qu'on retrouve
nos valeurs parce que là je trouve qu'on
perd vraiment notre emballé à cette
mentalité qu'on avait les dernières qui
nous a permis d'atteindre les barrages
pour la nationale 2 prochain match pour
plaisir le dimanche 27 janvier toujours
à domicile face à un autre concurrent
direct pour le maintien thionville
moselle handball l'avant dernier du
championnat victoire impérative pour
continuer à croire au maintien en fin de
saison
juste avant de vous laisser un mot de
handball féminin exactement of montigny
le bretonneux continue sa marche en
avant les mesures montrent elles ont
remporté une deuxième victoire
consécutive sur le terrain du paris
saint germain ce week-end les joueuses
de denys choulet se sont imposés 26 à 23
grâce notamment à 8 réalisations de
justin ribouleau au classement les
saint-quentinoises remontée se retrouve
maintenant à 7e place du classement avec
20 points
quatre petits points du podium merci
michael ce résultat et bien d'autres
encore à retrouver dans le 7-8 sport
notamment une grosse victoire des
templiers d'elancourt ans en football
américain on n'en dit pas plus on n'en
dit pas plus
juste avant de vous laisser prudence sur
les routes du département météo france a
placé les yvelines en vigilance orange
neige et les buts à partir de demain
mardi à 6h du matin
les engins de salage seront de sortie à
cette nuit à partir de 3h30 sur les
routes de saint quentin en yvelines et
pour être informés sur les opérations
dans l'agglomération inscrivez vous sur
peps point sky point fr voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]